Monica Rambo she's perfect she's
everything I'm kind of dressed like her
I look like her we're the same person
whatever Monica Rambo is the daughter of
Maria Rambo if you guys remember the
call sign Photon Carol danvers's pilot
friend in the 2019 Captain Marvel film
and one division though adult Monica
played by Tiana Parrott returned from
the blip to find Maria had died from
cancer Monica returned to sword where
her mom was the former director and
dealt with Wanda maximov's Westview
crisis that resulted in her getting her
radiated by The Cosmic radiation of
Wanda's hex though it was implied that
Monica had already been irradiated and
she had some bitterness with Carol One
Division ended with Monica getting
recruited by a scroll to join Nick Fury
who when we last saw him was hanging out
with the Scrolls on a different space
station in the post-credits scene of
Spider-Man far from home we'll see how
all of this ties in with the scroll
Spirit history of the secret invasion
anything